there is one major reason why i will be
upgrading to the iphone 14 pro and no it
is not because of the new cutouts and
getting rid of the notch in this video
i'm going to talk about the new info
that just came out along with giving you
guys the exact specifications and
showing you how much of a difference
this is actually going to make with
actual images so you know if it will be
worth it for you now personally i don't
really care that much about the cutouts
i know vadim is very excited about it
and it is nice getting rid of that
really dated notch but even though it's
gonna look better it doesn't really give
you that much screen real estate because
of that pill and then the circular
cutout for the camera what is going to
matter is the camera itself and not the
rear camera but the front one as well we
already know all of the information and
the full spec sheet list showing us
exactly what upgrades we're gonna get
and they are pretty major over the last
few months we've gotten a ton of
information about this new sensor and
not only is it gonna get much larger
which is a huge increase in size i'm
talking about 57
larger as far as surface area compared
to the already big sensor and the iphone
13 pro series making it literally bigger
than a lot of compact point-and-shoot
cameras so we're literally reaching a
new level now but along with that a
really big increase in tech but for the
first time ever jumping up from a 12
megapixel which we've had for many many
years up to 48 megapixels which is why
the actual camera bump is going to be
not only larger but also thicker as well
with the lenses protruding more
resulting in this massive camera module
that is huge compared to even the really
large one on the iphone 13. i mean just
look at that huge camera module now
vadim did a very deep dive going into
all of the tech the sensor sizes the
size of the pixels with quad bearing so
if you want all the fine detail you
should definitely check out that video
but this one isn't about that the new
info that we have is the apple is
ditching their chinese manufacturer for
the front-facing camera and going to one
from south korea now this change alone
isn't that massive but what is massive
is that it is going to cost apple three
times more money than in previous years
for the selfie camera meaning it is also
going to be a really big improvement now
they were originally going to do this
with the iphone 15 but they're doing it
a year early and that's great because in
some of these images well the iphone 13
pro gets killed by its android
competitors now what we know for sure
that there are two specific guaranteed
improvements the first being an f 1.9
lens which lets in more light and the
second being autofocus now with a lot of
android phones we already have this
where if you're pulling your phone
closer or further it will focus to make
sure your face is sharp whereas with the
iphone uh if you're putting it too far
away too close it will not be as
detailed so let's go ahead and jump in
and let me show you exactly what kind of
photo quality improvements we can expect
along with some changes in video and
also some possible downsides for the
iphone 14 pros let's start out with this
image right here you can see that the
pixel 6 pro's shot looks much more
detailed than the iphone even though
it's a less expensive phone that is
because the pixel google is using a 50
megapixel main sensor where apple has a
12 megapixel as they've had for years
upgrading to that 48 megapixel sensor
that we know that is coming is going to
greatly improve the detail level this is
something that i wanted for years
because it is a downside i mean look at
this shot it shows it so plainly how
much more detailed the pixel 6 photo is
when we zoom in 200 percent you notice a
drastic difference in actual detail of
every image you take and that's not only
the case for the pixel 6 samsung's had
high resolution sensors for a long time
now and in this shot you see that the
samsung image is much more detailed this
is without that much of a crop and
that's not only the case in daytime
photos at night with that quad bearing
or samsung's nine layered bear down to a
12 megapixel you see that this night
shot is so much more detailed than
apple's and this is something that we've
consistently found in our blind unbiased
camera comparison test that having the
extra resolution really helps now
apple's done a great job with deep
fusion they've done an amazing job with
portraits but at this point we are
hitting a wall with a 12 megapixel
sensor and also with the front facing
camera i'll show you in just a bit if
you watch these comparisons it just
shows you how much the high resolution
sensors of android are getting far ahead
now from apple's iphone now people say
that iphones have gotten so good you
don't need to have a dslr anymore but
what people fail to mention is that
dslrs and lenses have gotten much better
and most of them are using much higher
resolutions as well for example i just
went on a trip to phoenix and i took a
real camera with me and on the right
here we have our iphone shot that looks
great but if you care about detail and
you're gonna look closer or do any sort
of cropping you could see how much
better a 50 megapixel sensor looks
compared to iphone's 12 megapixel now
apple does a shockingly good job with
hdr and processing but then if we go
ahead and take a little bit of a closer
look not just on your phone the quality
difference of the actual photo is
dramatic in terms of detail that it
captures i mean look at this you can
actually see all the fine little spikes
on the cactus compared to a bunch of
artifacts and just kind of mush there
and in this shot without even zooming in
you could tell that the image on the
left looks a lot more detailed and then
if we take a closer look i mean that
quality difference is dramatic now you
don't need a dslr to get shots that are
this detailed samsung is offering this
and even google with the pixel series
and a lot of other android phones have
been doing this for a couple years now i
know some people will say well the
iphone's already good enough i don't
really care about photo quality but i
have a different perspective on it
people take all their photos or most of
them with their smartphone and these are
the memories you're gonna have for the
next 20 years 30 years are going to show
it to your kids your grandkids and our
parents had great photos from film
cameras to show us where the detail is
really good and if we're taking photos
that are mushy looking and not great i
mean to me that's one reason why i want
to have the latest iphone or an android
phone to capture memories that you're
going to have for a lifetime now that
doesn't only go into detail on that rear
camera this is where the front-facing
camera the iphone has really fallen
apart compared to androids over the last
couple years if you take a look at this
shot right here with the s22 ultra they
are using a 40 megapixel front facing
camera and it looks so much better than
the iphone the hdr looks better and the
detail and the face the skin tones it's
not as flat it looks way better this is
why i've been tempted to use an android
phone and even take an android phone on
my vacation to get shots like this i
mean it's dramatically better if you had
to choose one of these to keep forever
which photo would you choose i would
obviously choose the samsung image and
even at night time with that pixel
binning it looks much more like an
actual real camera than having a
smartphone like image this is the kind
of quality that we can expect
with this upgrade from apple on both the
front-facing camera and that rear-facing
camera now of course with that going up
to 48 megapixel will allow for 8k video
the apple has not had samsung samsung's
been offering this for a few years now
but if you take a look the shot on the
left actually looks worse than the shot
on the right which is the iphone
shooting 4k instead of ak that is
because they're going with 108 megapixel
sensor that's to crop in a ton it needs
a lot more processing so it turns out
looking worse than apple's 4k and
because of that their night mode video
even in 4k
looked much worse than apples and this
is why apple chose to go with the 48
megapixel sensor it's perfect for 8k and
it's gonna make it look amazing without
any of the downsides i honestly cannot
wait for this camera upgrade so what are
gonna be the downsides if we have these
massive improvements well as far as we
know only the main camera is going to go
up to 48 megapixel the front-facing one
might get a bump up too but we're not
yet sure we don't have that information
i really hope it does but as far as the
ultra right in the telephoto it's going
to stay the same we're not going to get
one of those telescopic cameras so you
look at this image here the pixel 6 pro
looks so much more detailed than the
iphone because of its 48 megapixel
telephoto camera whereas the iphone is
still stuck at 12. and with that the
ultra right is also going to stay at 12
megapixel so you look at the image on
the right it looks so much more detailed
than the iphone's camera now that
doesn't mean that it can't prove
software can improve maybe the low light
sensitivity to have some improvements
but it's not going to be as massive as a
jump as the rear 48 megapixel camera so
both of those are still going to be less
detailed than many of its android
counterparts which is a bummer at least
to me when i see these kind of photos
and how far ahead some of the android
phones currently are of course we still
have some time and it would be amazing
if apple upgrades the other cameras as
well and we get more info but you guys
go ahead and let me know is this enough
for you to want to upgrade your phone
how much do you care about quality and
the iphone being multiple years behind
compared to some of the androids does
that matter to you do you care we want
to hear your thoughts down below go
ahead and click that subscribe button
above if you guys want to see more
videos like this help us reach a million
subscribers check out the in-depth depth
detailed video about the main camera
system right over there this max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]